all right so we're gonna be recording a
video with my beautiful mother now
so mom there she is so mom what do you
have to say about anything that's on
your mind what are you thinking about
history prosperity of the society and
future I think we can connect past with
future
yeah I create a beautiful age and
structures
the history
really hard
yeah I agree there's this we're here in
Italy and we have the blessing of
looking at all the history in the art
and architecture and it's it's the past
like you said but we have the future
behind us as well with all those
skyscrapers and I saw when we were at
the subway station I saw that there was
a program on television they were
teaching about science and technology
and so it was very interesting seeing
that they like you just said how do we
blend together the future in the past
[Music]
it's that intergenerational wisdom and
the importance of of going from you know
your generation of mine and from
grandmas and and and that's the same
thing for your families everyone that's
tuning and how do you take what your
grandparents thought your parents and
how they teach you and how do we keep
the intergenerational wisdoms over time
because people still need to appreciate
the design and architecture of things
like this but also it's important to
understand the science and futurism that
we're going to - thanks for thanks for
talking with us
it's nice having mom shed some wisdom
every once in a while
I love you thanks